[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sortez couverts
[Musique]
à
y accéder
[Musique]
comment un camouflet s'il est évident
c'est quoi bachetta tu me connais
beaucoup comme ça
bon bah ouais bah
[Musique]
un peu à peu un peu dans tous les sens
car les guiboles
ça dépasse un peu partout à commencer ya
longtemps petite dizaine d'années on le
descend à redescendre
m
mais lui dans la zone aussi je partis
aussi aussi par là bas n'ont jamais osé
et pourquoi pas s'amuse à résister
athènes
[Musique]
les alouettes en a beaucoup comme ça moi
aussi je crois qu'il convient pas on les
cache
[Musique]
cette élite et nice et moi c'est
l'emblème des eaux la thonaille c'est
parce que je suis célèbre tourne mal de
dons on est copains sont cotisés pour
acheter un joli travail savent celui non
pas d'anglais et sur la vie de la mère
ou encore bien trop mais mon corps et ça
c'est vraiment parce que ça me fait
marrer
le platine pour moi c'est pourquoi
savourer
[Musique]
c'est toi c'est beau et on a percé pour
de vrai pour avoir des trous partout et
ça fait quoi du bien c'était excitant
ouais il semblerait il a tu les fais
quoi dans doute pas dans l'oreille dans
les sens talât dans les cintres art est
à prévoir ouais d'accord et qu'elle
servait et que ça te fait bah rien quand
je me balade torse nu sur la plage
peuvent être plus des comme ça
mais est-ce que c'est excitant
ouais c'est cool toute la journée cette
excitante la journée je me couche ah
ouais dans la queue dans l'ain bientôt
il s'appelle comment déjà que ça peut
durer plusieurs n'ont pas la langue le
prince albert
le prince albert c'était le prince
albert kahn avait un seul monaco en
france un père de la reine victoria
il y en avait un vrai parce qu'il avait
la queue qui bandent est tout le temps
et
djilali pour cela crochet que vous avez
des pantalons moulants l'époque seul lé
accroché ces trous dedans ça il
accrochera chant et ça se voyait pas
qu'ils vendent je suis pas responsable
c'est les filles je m'étonne avons
vraiment c'est bien c'est qu'on s'est
dit que c'était pour rire jouer rires
c'est une association qui va bien tu vas
le faire alors dans l'accueil l'échangé
prévu en fait c'est parce que moi j'aime
bien travailler d'esthétique un petit
toit avec tant qu'à faire
c'est toujours chouette
et là j'ai prévu un truc je voulais pas
commencer avant savoir exactement les
mettre sur les tribus 11
c'est bien de riz car c'est le premier
ricard que je vois moi cette année au
revoir merci a pas vu c'est le premier
écart que je vois cette année
bâtie j'ai vu des bonnes gens moi j'ai
une théorie quand je vois des bourgeons
les premiers bourgeons sur les sur les
arbres ouais je bois un écart bon bah
alors qu'il a vu le froid moi c'était
pour moi c'est le premier de l'année
hier tu sais quand les jours commencent
à rallonger et qui a des cas des biens
agents sur les arbres platanes voix en
normandie ça y est les premiers
bourgeons donc ça y est les premiers
ricains mais on filme en longs que la
nuit tu t'en aperçois qu il ya du bon
temps à bâle week-end je regarde pousser
mézard mois stephen roth ses chances
moi je suis ça prend du temps et c'est
ça qui est bien et bien c'est que ça
prend du temps mais le nombre
ça occupe ah oui regarder pousser un
arbre c'est ça prend toute une vie
yonath approuvé de saison c'est
important d'en turet que des lampes je
vois que nous avons à faire les
agriculteurs ça peut changer beaucoup
finalement non non c'est jean ballarin
que jean lacrampe à des gens la vraie
campagne des primes ici c'est un peu sur
le terme primitifs modernes car là on
est à montmartre alors vous avez
démarche arrêté conneries ah bah tiens
toi ça nous aider beaucoup les mecs à
celle que j'avais beaucoup aimé mon
étude parle
oh la la bah dis donc assez cool ça
c'est bien non pour vous hein ça marche
très bien le piercing sauta touche hope
they know that her way we sacré vide
oui et toi oui impec ouais voilà c'est
cool un voile et ses plans et c'est là
que tu bosses est ce que c'est celle
optique qui voit s'estomper lentilles
qui voit sa voix j'ai pas le nerd savard
tu as tu passé assez les gros pots est
là il parle il parle boutique la non 90
63 la haye il est bien suivre ses
solides gentiment présidera une couche
sur le ventre moi si je me faisais tu as
tout et ça sera au tour du cou des
pointillés avec marc et couper ici
ouais ah ça je trouve ça génial tu
trouves pas ça bien ne pas passer autour
du cou des petits pointillés avec marc
et couper ici tu sais ce que ça veut
dire non mais vraiment un des vieilles
symbolique de tatouage de tout l'argent
cayenne plan comme ça et normalement les
mecs qui sont ces autour du cou et
autour des autour des poignets ça veut
dire faudrait qu'on me coupe la tête et
les mains pour que j'arrête de voler ah
ouais d'accord comme quand tu vois des
mecs avec des petits traits sur les
bords des yeux c'est par sf au placard
et ça veut dire j'ai fait pleurer ma
mère c'est pas très grave il ya votre
grand tatouage que ça me battre batta ni
dieu ni maître le pont du maquereau
totalement c'est quoi un point sur la
joue c'est whittall battle le
traditionnel le grand classique voilà
ici présent le dire quoi sa mort aux
vaches mort aux flics
ouais moi au conte
[Musique]
en de la rue saint-vincent impôts été
connue
c'est mr l'espace d'un instant mais il
ne l'a
a jamais revus cette chanson
il composa espérant que
sont inconnus
[Applaudissements]
un matin de printemps
on entendra
quelque part au coin
d'une rue
à l'une problème pose un diadème sur tes
cheveux roux
la lune trop douce de gloire
éclaboussent son jupon plein de trous la
lune trop barcarès europe râle de tes
yeux blasé
le mettre dans son antre ça va ça va
arriver c'est quoi ces tables ça c'est
pour le spectacle de l'après midi ah oui
les appeler et bien oui voilà l'âge d'or
c'est une façon de se projeter 20 ans en
arrière avec des vedettes
toujours en grande forme d'ailleurs des
années
70 par exemple par exemple annie gould a
nié good et ça marche très bien
j'en suis sûr parce que mon mon rêve
c'est de faire puisqu'il faut
positionner un établissement de
spectacle c'est de faire de gobineau un
théâtre des seniors avec c'est le
marketing des seniors enfin le marketing
il ya un marché qui existent qu'on a
beaucoup sous-estimé pas ce que les
publicitaires se sont gargarisés pendant
des années de la ménagère de moins de 50
ans fut finalement ce qui est plus
important aujourd'hui sur le plan
économique c'est la ménagère de plus de
50 ans alors c'est à cela que je pense
et puis donc mais aussi la façon de de
s'autoriser à retrouver des amis
d'enfance le ça va ça marche bien la
démission non gentiment un vaisseau
réseau en temps il arrive qu'on fasse
pas des millions de gens c'est arrivé
une fois non temps en temps même c'est
quand on est un gagnant il faut essayer
d'être en même temps un gagnant ouais
c'est pas pour moi je vous dis un
producteur général
vous allez faire ça combien de temps
encore oh je crois que le plus gros et
faire pense que la littérature disait
michel audiard c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
agréable parce que on peut continuer à
exercer son métier alors qu'on est
complètement gâteux dans d'autres
disciplines c'est plus visible et il
faut savoir se retirer
m'enfin bon j'ai eu un moment quand même
un moment de doute et je ne vous
cacherai pas parce que je sais que vous
aimez bien les les états d'âme moment de
panique fait cinq ans que j'en avais
appris ça moi je moi j'étais vachement
sympa avant de voir samedi soir la série
clavier plaint que c'est elle qui aller
beaucoup plus loin que la mienne et je
j'ai eu peur quand j'ai atteint 65 ans
parce qu'il ya 65 ans dans notre type de
société il ya un couple à la retraite
des fonctionnaires est qu au sénégal
après bon moi j'ai vu tellement de gens
qui à 64 ans et 364 jours ont eu droit
pêle-mêle mais en une heure seulement
remerciements du ptg au vin d'honneur et
au rocking chair et puis bon mort
socialement à la fin de la manifestation
que
je me suis dit je suis pas comment je
vais prendre ça parce que moi
contrairement à bouger pas de lobby
j'élève pas d'animaux jeune intérieur
pas de sport bobby dû entièrement ville
qu'est ce qu'il faut entendre
et puis à 65 ans et un jour je me suis
aperçu qu'aucun de mes employeurs
n'avaient saisi cette occasion de se
débarrasser de moi ce qui prouve que ce
sont des gens sympathiques mais de
mauvais gestionnaires et que ça
continuer et même que ça continuait de
plus belle
hassen espèce de satisfaction parce que
on est paniquée à l'idée de ne plus rien
faire mais surtout à l'idée que les
autres vont faire un tas de choses sans
vous alors moi je j'essaie d'abord comme
je l'aï toujours fait de ne pas prendre
en grippe la société qui me nourrit pas
mal jusqu'à présent et ensuite de
considérer bah oui mais moi j'ai dû
ventes mais cela il m'avait prévenue
trop tard pour que je puisse me ferait
trop riche
puis ensuite bas
il faut
mangez beaucoup non comment vous aimez
bien manger je mange beaucoup et vite
oui et longtemps mais
je suis écouté on isole dérange pas tant
mais tant que ça vous dérange et je vais
vous dire non seulement ça me dérange
pas mais nous sommes dans des
professions où il faut inspirer
confiance et ça c'est l'ego visite rhône
qui est d'ailleurs mort d'autres choses
et qui disait on ne dit jamais un bon
maigre on dit toujours un bon gros seins
alors je vous dis pas que
ceignac l'obésité qui peut vous ouvrir
le coeur des gens oui enfin bon je me
suis bien comme ça et je me vois pas
filiforme
vous n'avez pas envie de vous emmerder à
faire un régime ou quoi c'est clair non
j'ai fait un peu de régime mais c'était
plutôt de la suralimentation
beaucoup
lemon aller sur scène on peut pas entrer
pointe ont donné par les prénoms mais
pas quand elle est sur scène même à
temps ouais non mais peut pas vous
attendre maintenant c'est impossible
mais pas lui parler non non on peut pas
lui parler maintenant elle est sûre je
dirais qu'on est venu bien sûr on le
dira
kaboul
je présente de fred
les chats service elle est pas là mais
vonn à quelle heure elle vient
maman vous lui dites qu'on est passé
je voulais la voir
vous y pensez
c
m
le bon ton
monsieur monsieur vous lui dites qu'on
ait passé un animal un volume d'émission
merci au revoir c'est un hall du siège
approche du matériel
mélange de mes désirs
j'irai si senna prost ukrainien
si son approche
[Musique]
les bons de chalain n'est ce pas qu'il
est beau c'est quoi comme chien un boxer
mélange avec un berger belge
oh là là là là là ça doit se marier ces
bêtes là bas est normalement les deux
parents 20 pedigree il n'aurait pas dû
se marier on les en empêcher c'est la
famille angleterre voilà et ça fait ça
fait ça ça fait neuf ans que je l'ait
pas que un peu ses deux lancers de
l'arthrose avant c'est comme nous quand
on a dit on à tisme un oui mais je donne
des cachets je vais pas encore donné je
lui donnais tout à l'heure ouais vous
faites quoi
ben je promenais mon chien je vais
rentrer à la maison tout simplement
mais si vous voulez venir prendre un
verre pourquoi paraissent pas dans la
vie vous fait quoi un show sur man a dit
des choses oui en discothèque avant mais
oui ok le disque dans toutes les
discothèques de france
ça s'appelle qui est devenue l'enjeu
bleus
tu as mal à la papa tu prouves db
eh bien on rentre bien dans amara
enfin la mare ton avis si bédié
c'est un peu comme quoi ici non c'est
pas trop bien fréquentée avant il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de problèmes de
drogue mais apparemment ça l'air de
s'arranger avec beaucoup drogué beaucoup
de revendeurs mais la police il ya mis
son lay ça va beaucoup mieux
sans ça oui on est bien il vendait quoi
même des l'héroïne du shit fin ils ont
des taux tout et rien enfin bon avec le
chien m'embête pas comment il s'appelle
de cibus allez vas-y bb1 faut rentrer la
saline
alors que je te retire la lèze bébé à
temps rires je crois que j'ai coupé la
télé non attends allez maintenant le
divan sommes allés à coucy son livre oui
farce et c'est sa place alors on m'a dit
que vous aviez parlé dans ce domaine
belles photos de sévices
c'est votre jean-jack queyranne qu'elle
vient stallone un ouais mais ça c'est
qui c'est mon fils alors en quoi il
était dense est finie la gamme en trois
ans et va réveiller ça y est on n'avait
pas travaillé d'affaires mais bon ça va
bonsoir on attend ils peuvent avec la
salle où il a trouvé la parade
un siège pourrait se mettre là le ch oui
puissance avec les food high tech
l'appel sont dans la charme sièges ouais
bien arrosée mais je crois que tirer les
pikes peak toi oui dans mes notes dettes
avait un beau portrait de staline
je l'aï les fous de dieu ni d'ailleurs
avant que vous arriviez on a écouté deux
heures de 12 à l'écouté quoi les
concerts de johnny que j'ai pris mon
magnétoscope away son concert d' des 50
ans et parc des princes fait voir mes
envies ou l'inde ou chez vous en cuira
mince on entre on enregistre la victoire
aux points
moi ton tona repas le fanatique là on
peut atteindre celle de le faire parce
que c'est ce qui va faire va tu sais où
se situer
j'ai acheté une bouteille de whisky la
presse que vidal et s'avance avant tirs
j'avais acheté bouteille faut quand même
avoir un regard un regard dont jalila
oui oui mais c'est quoi comme risqués
s'est resserré c'est pas une marque
connue ce une marque si j'attaque arfa
leclerc mais bon il est bon c'est ça ça
me paraît oui ça saoule bien ces dix
stades suisses qui a way j'espérais
qu'il serait assez souple on dort mieux
et nous laisser tranquilles mais
manquent de poule nous il aurait
travaillé comme une porte s ouvrit
c'est pas mal mais sympa jean louis est
très gentil les jaloux un peu j'ai passé
six ans à bord ouais mais non mais bon
ça me dit on est jaloux de ce qu'on aime
bien sûr que c'est ce que je fais parce
que je suis il est déjà venu avec moi
bien que ce qu'il veut quand même pas
trop mais enfin pour l'argent il est
bien obligé de me laisser faire
et alors ben il est venu à la
discothèque qui s'est bien amusé il a
participé à sa condition actuelle à
voile sur scène ça te fait quoi quand
as-tu fait elle fait des strip-teases sa
seconde opa dans ces cas là c'est
différent mais sérieux c'est bah ça lui
fait plaisir d'un côté ça le salon
pikine plaute quoi qui fait en sorte que
les mecs n'approche pas trop mais pas
celle de défendre tout seul en face ont
formé un coût de cinq tournois alors
toute façon c'est pas grave
non mais je sais qu'il fait tous les
combien les choses sur seine aube
beaucoup moins maintenant un coût moins
15 ans dans l'industrie leader parce que
c'est jamais moi qui demande aux
discothèques qui m'appelle oui il ya un
salon des discothèques deux fois dans
l'année j'y vais je ne fais pas je fasse
mes coordonnées puis on met la série un
gars m'en fais des films mais j'avais
dit qu'il faisait en effet avant d'être
avec lui j'ai arrêté de que je fais avec
front social non 5 ou 6 et tout le pays
je veux plus en faire parce qu'ils
veulent par ce protégé un maître pas de
préservatif avec le sida moi je suis pas
lui dire fais décida donc je suis avec
lui je sais qu'il a rien j'ai rien
puisque je fais ça une époque de ma vie
pour élever mes enfants mais maintenant
j'ai plus besoin de ça
les enfants étant guidé jamais de la c1
grande histoire d'amour c'est quand même
temps vous êtes ensemble 6
j'appuie vous êtes connus comme en fête
de la musique dallière dans un café un
mammouth et lunettes de soleil timbale
aux yeux j'ai connu tempête
ouais donc c'est connu dans un cadre et
c'était la fête de la musique un écrit
bon puis voilà puis son frère est un de
mes meilleurs amis de tous savaient
qu'ils avaient à faire
pas vraiment evelyne face et si jamais
ça partait en courant
et là c'est cette finale louis ménard on
se dispute enfin cela m'a commandé
couple ils veulent ainsi si j'étais pas
fidèles ils en voudraient si sion 13 mai
puis avec lui j'ai pas fait un pas à
côté puis j'en ai pas envie d'allaiter
dix cantons ainsi na waie alors il a
toujours la pression que dans le métier
que je fais puisque je suis aussi
comédienne en plus des discothèques dans
ce métier là on trompe facilement mais
c'est pas vrai du tout c'est pas vrai du
tout mais moi
à noter qu'à six barrettes tu pourrais
pas mal d'ailleurs cherché à whisky plus
grand risque
oui tu as les vertus les c'est bien beau
mais si je fus tu as tu peux attention
vous avez déjà bien l'arroser la soirée
non non c'est l'adopter pavois c'est une
question ou jamais oui c'est moi
le trio dernier que j'ai fait je me suis
fait avoir c'est elle est tombée dans
les visiteurs ils ont tourné les
visiteuses et j'ai tombé dedans à
tempérer les visiteuses oui j'avais un
rôle comique à 1
j'avais un rôle quoi ça mais qu'est ce
qu'un bon nombre de films ça ça marchait
bien mais j'en ai un peu forte
c'est bien toi et moi j'en veux bien ou
ce match 4 voire deux mais ça marche
oui ça marche bien mais bon moi je
n'atteins de 50 ans n'ont pas encore
bien oui à ces voix là bas ils savent
les visites est ce qu ils savent que
j'ai fait les visiteurs clavier
normalement bas les visiteuses tu sais
je suis toulouse 1-3 une petite dose me
donne je crois qu'il n'est pas prêt de
faire autrement on a vu un double top
stocks arrive du poker comme ça je juste
trentenaire membres moi je veux bien peu
de coke avec chéri comme m6 gagne pour
un show dans une discothèque
6 enfin je demande c'est ce que jean
jacques ça ça c'est la vérité mais il
voit les fiches de paye tout cela est
quand même page il montre cependant le
problème des discothèques maintenant
c'est qu'elles veulent plus nous
déclarer ouais donc je peux pas faire
des discothèques plupart en attendant
c'est trouver de quoi de plus normal si
j'en fais mais je veux pas faire des
quotas qui me déclare pas et après avoir
dézingué avec les intégrateurs
ouais parce que en ce moment ils sont
durs avec les gens du spectacle des
élèves genesis envoie à paris ces fiches
de paye
mais c'est pas ma course qu'il pourrait
vous faire dire si travail qu'il a mené
beaucoup d'argent et fait plutôt le
contraire est alors que beaucoup de gars
sa place à pas agi comme ça je reconnais
maintenant il a du fond jean-jacques ma
phobie
ouais
qu'est ce que vous faites a gelé la
gelée c'est bon il faut qui démarre sa
pub en fait là je prélève là je fais un
prélèvement de démission d'hydrocarbures
c'est pourquoi pour un laboratoire
c'est pour le musée des nuages à il faut
qu'il démarre là j'en ai assez c'est ça
le boulot quand même donc la c1 c'est un
nuage invisible d'hydrocarbures eni par
cet autobus etc pour l'usiné nuages ont
fait une collection de nuages alors il
ya des nuages naturel et puis aussi des
nuages artificiels de différentes
natures
si on peut s'adresser au juge et des
nuages
voilà maintenant je vais le mettre au
milieu des nuages c'est partout c'est
partout partout où on respire partout on
lève la tête
partout on peut voir parce qu'un nuage
chez de l'eau au départ un phénomène
visible qui rend le lot qui donne un
concert visible et puis le
et alors c'est qu'est-ce qui a d'autres
dans le donc là il ya on voit rien on
voit rien mais il ya nuages que j'ai
capturé pour les collections du musée
donc un musée du budget des nuages s'est
amusé de l'invisible c'est un musée qui
qui essaie de rendre le visible visible
voilà maintenant ça alors j'ai j'ai eu
le bus de nuit alors que je fasse une
fiche là maintenant après avoir
identifié le bouquin d'amplifier et puis
je on m'a demandé de prendre des nuages
de vapeur toxique là pour ce soir
donc je verrai je cherchais un café très
enfumée dans lequel on puisse aussi fait
tourner la tête
pas très bien mais dans lequel je puisse
capturer des caps tdd des émissions de
fumée de tabac etc des émissions
toxiques donc si je crois que vous
connaissez un des cafés qui sont à ses
employés allaient ensemble si vous
voulez fait aux baisses c'est vous qui
allez me guide et vous me dites parce
que moi je n'ai pas vraiment d'idée je
pense que vous connaissez bien farik
d'accord on y va
il ya longtemps que vous faites ça
l'amusé des nuages existe depuis 88 ans
environ ouais est bon les prélèvements
ils ont ils ont commencé au même moment
ça fait presque dix ans quand vous
faites des prélèvements de fumée oui
c'est ça ça fait à peu près peut-être
peut-être 10 enfin on a on a beaucoup de
temps devant nous encore pour continuer
à en faire parce que c'est toute une
organisation
il faut vous avez combien de bocal chez
vous ça c'est ce sont des personnes qui
vont à l'inventaire qui pourrait vous
dire ça moi je sais pas exactement qui
est moi je travaille surtout sur les
prélèvements
vous êtes nombreux musées des nuages on
est un
c'est là votre café soir
soir aujourd'hui suffisamment j'oublie
voilà donc là j'ai fait une fiche pour
cet arrêt de bus alors donc prélèvements
nature du prélèvement ses émissions
d'hydrocarbures la date 23 février 96 le
lieu donc ces arrêts de bus pc paris ces
petites ceintures pce qui peint une
petite ceinture
bon là c'est la ligne sur twitter nous
intéresse un signe qui tourne la nuit et
donc
c'est pas si l'institution donc là il
faut sauver pas que ça s'échappe
je vais matériel qui inscrivait désolé
que ça va coller ça respecte va coller
voit la première chose
alors il fait froid qu'il fait c'est pas
facile d'écrire un mais bon maintenant
c'est bien parce que c'est la partie la
plus grave c'est que je préfère ces
prélèvements
c'est alors c'est un prélèvement et là
on m'a demandé de faire un événement
passé dans un endroit alors apparemment
une situation qu il ya des ventilateurs
mais c'est quand même ça revient donc je
vais là c'est un bocal qui été
stérilisés que je nous ai je vais
attendre que l'atmosphère et l'ambiance
jusqu'à tripler naître un petit peu dans
sa danseuse dans cet endroit
et puis on va tendre problème c'est qui
battant qui trouve
[Musique]
oulala
tu goûtes voilà ben mouaïa en commençant
par les vicois vidéo et comment ça se
passe avec les costumes que vous agirez
je racontais pourquoi c'est pas très
bien côté qu cois on va commencer à
saviez vous que du talon aiguille
lui y est méticuleusement fouillé avec
un gros décolleté est arrivé comme prévu
pas pris c'est la première fois qu'elle
sort du traité comme un bon rythme tu
m'a dit tu l'a sodomisée un premier soir
et quoi d'autre de plus disons de plus
de plus sympathique que ça que cette
position il ya quoi même l'écart est
trouvé ça bon alors comment comment tu
va opérer pour ton père franchement tu
voulais dire papa poule e te dise un
truc je te parle
elle est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est
au courant que tu vas le dire à ton père
elle voudrait pas à mon avis sur minitel
qui te dit ceci il faut que tu dis cela
papa j'ai baisé belle maman
je
m
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
la tête de vos conquêtes et puis je vais
les laisser se présenter même temps les
gars bon yes bank présent ricardo de
laminoirs à côté de moi j'ai caressé
fils de l'anif a pas changé de style
européenne christo le barbare et son
look tout ce qu on leur balance à nos
miss chick laurier chic moustache iton
klaus le charbon pourraient être
présentes concession de thiais que ça où
les routes d'autres
sa position de la belgique y est
également pour le blanc voilà le maca le
mec a acheté le pavillon à côté lac a
travaillé toute sa vie pour s'acheter le
pavillon à côté je vais être content
avant j'entends rien le mec non quand
c'est bien fait mais ça va on connaît
tous la famille tu voir tous mes copains
l'utilité professionnelle ça nous sommes
frappés comme tout le monde quoi doit
jamais nous saluons le profond
s'il ya la boue par la sono baba diassé
aux classes à l'ouest de la ville a été
mon club et je sais pas c'est quoi c'est
la grande famille le temple du hip hop
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu